Alpha blended
transparency-- it's
one of those awesome effects
that really helps sell an app.
It's not cheap, but it's
worth the cost, right?
Well, what if I told you that
you're paying more for alpha
blending than you have to?
My name is Ian Ni-Lewis,
and in the next few minutes
I'm going to introduce you to
a hidden cost of alpha blending
on Android, and I'm going to
show you two ways to avoid it.
Now, you probably already
know why alpha blending costs
more than opaque rendering.
When you render
an opaque element,
you only need to write
to each pixel once,
but when you're
blending, you have
to draw every pixel
at least twice.
That's because we
need to know what's
underneath our alpha blended
view in order to blend with it.
But did you know that
alpha blending also
has a hidden cost?
Under some conditions, a
single alpha blended view
can cause an entire branch
of your view hierarchy
to be drawn twice.
Here's a real world example;
it's a fancy list view,
and it uses alpha
blending to tint
the photos and the subtitles.
Now under normal
conditions, each element
is drawn directly to the
screen back to front.
If an element has alpha, it's
blended with whatever colors
are already on the screen.
But let's say that we wanted
to take this entire list view
and reduce its
transparency a little bit.
Now, that's pretty common.
Lots of apps these days
use animated transparency
and transitions to make it
look like a view is fading out.
As we decrease the
alpha value, you
can see the view
start to fade into
the light-colored background.
But what you can't see is that
we've just triggered a hidden
extra drawing step.
You see, when the entire
view becomes transparent,
our previous rendering
strategy doesn't work.
If you just draw each
element at the reduced alpha,
you'd start getting
colors blending
in where there shouldn't be.
Now, check out the
title text on the left
and compare it to the
same text on the right.
The one on the left is correct,
and it's still bright white.
The text on the right,
on the other hand,
is starting to fade into
the colored background.
You can see the same problem
with the photos, too.
Their picking up a little
more tint from the background
than they're supposed to.
So how does the renderer
get the right result?
Well, it has to use a
two-pass drawing technique.
It begins by drawing the
entire view as normal,
at full opacity.
But it doesn't draw
directly to the screen.
Instead, it draws
it to an off screen
buffer called a hardware layer.
Now, hardware layers
are pretty cool.
The GPU is really, really
good at copying pixels
from hardware layers
to the screen,
and it can do some neat
tricks like scale and rotation
and transparency during
the copy process,
and that's exactly
what the renderer does
in the second drawing pass.
It tells the GPU to
copy all of the pixels
from the hardware
layer to the screen,
and it applies the new
alpha value in the process.
So why does this cause
a performance problem?
Well, it's because
hardware layers
are one of those things that
has a large upfront cost
and then gets cheaper over time.
The first time you
use a layer, it's
more expensive than just
drawing directly to the screen.
The savings come later,
as you reuse the layer
without changing its contents.
But in the case we're looking
at, we never see those savings.
Why?
Because after every
frame, the renderer
throws the hardware layer away.
Every single time we draw this
view, we have to pay the setup
and draw costs all over again.
Now, at first, this
probably sounds
like the renderer is
making a dumb decision,
but that's not really the case.
Those offscreen
buffers take up memory,
and the renderer
doesn't have a good way
of knowing whether or when you
might want to reuse that image,
so it's making THE
smart choice given
the information that it has.
So how do we give the
renderer better information?
Well, first, we can
tell the renderer
to keep that
hardware layer AROUND
by calling views
dot setLayerType
with LAYER_TYPE_HARDWARE.
Now, this will tell the
renderer to reuse the layer
and make the drawing operation
nearly twice as fast.
Just don't forget to
set the layer type back
to LAYER_TYPE_NONE
when you're done,
so you don't waste precious
video memory for nothing.
If you're targeting
API 16 or above,
you can use a shortcut
called ViewPropertyAnimator
dot withLayer to have the
animator manage the layer
type automatically.
Now, another common example
is a view with a drop shadow.
This kind of view has an opaque
part and a semi transparent
part, but it's never going to
run into the draw order problem
that we saw earlier, and that's
because the two parts don't
overlap.
If they don't overlap,
then it doesn't matter
what order they get drawn in.
So we can let the renderer
know about this condition
by overriding view dot
hasOverlappingRendering.
If that method returns
false, then the renderer
won't create a
hardware buffer; it'll
draw the view in just one pass.
This can make a big difference
to draw performance.
In our sample app, setting the
overlap rendering flag to false
cut our draw time in half.
You don't actually have to
have non-overlapping content
to use this flag.
If you specify on a view that
does have overlapping content,
you'll still get that
same performance benefit.
You just won't get 100%
correct alpha blending.
Whether that's a
bad thing or not
depends on your application.
Just remember, even if you do
make a view draw twice as fast,
that may or may not make
your entire app faster.
Always profile your
code and find out
where the hotspots are
before you make any changes.
There's tons more tips and
tricks available to improve
your rendering performance
at the Android Performance
Patterns homepage, and don't
forget to join our Google+
community for more great info.
And remember, keep
calm, profile your code,
and, as always, perf matters.